We started to predict this months ago when
it became clear that vote by mail or as I
am now calling it, absentee by mail voting
would be a huge dividing line in the upcoming
presidential election.
Also, don't forget, it will be a big deal
in the Senate, maybe remaining in Republican
control, maybe going to Democratic control.
They are going to be trying to stop vote by
mail and stop absentee voting.
They're not even trying to hide it.
I already told you that Donald Trump put a
donor of his named Lewis Dejoy in charge of
the post office as postmaster general.
We suspected that Dejoy would try to hurt
the post offices ability to deliver mail.
Dejoy has already limited overtime for mail
carriers, which is causing mail to pile up
at post offices across the country.
More cutbacks are now being discussed.
But now the big breaking news is that Dejoy
has reassigned or fired more than two dozen
top postal officials specifically.
Two people have been removed.
Twenty three have been reassigned.
Anyone whose priorities are deliver, the mail
is being moved.
And instead, Dejoy seems to be sort of centralizing
his power, consolidating the higher echelons
of the postal service with people that are
friendly to his truck, pro Trump priorities.
And this is the mail that we're talking about.
Ladies and gentlemen, if I had told you a
year ago the 2020 presidential election could
come down, not to the economy, not to Donald
Trump's foreign policy.
It could come down to whether a Trump donor
succeeds at kneecapping and crippling the
post office.
I don't think any of us would have believed
that that was a likely scenario.
It's the scenario today and this is all having
an immediate effect.
There are already many reports coming in from
around the country about mail delivery being
slowed down and degraded.
There are reports of mail carriers having
to sort mail themselves something that's usually
done for them when they arrive and they're
ready to take out their mail for the day.
It would already be sorted.
They're having to sort it themselves, slows
them down even more.
There are reports of mail bins that should
have been delivered already, sitting at post
offices unsorted and undelivered.
And the sickest thing of it all.
Is the backwards logic of everything, Trump
claimed that if there were too many absentee
ballots, the post office couldn't handle the
volume of mail.
The post office said we can handle it just
fine unless you kneecap the post office, which
is exactly what they're doing.
They are making it so that the post office
will not be able to handle even the normal
mail delivery work.
It's like a Trojan horse.
You don't have to be.
I hope you don't have to be anti Trump to
realize how evil this is.
Right.
I mean, will approach Trump.
What will the pro trump people in my audience?
I know you're there.
Will you come forward and say this is playing
dirty.
This is anti-democratic.
This has to be stopped.
It's completely indefensible.
And this they talk about election fraud.
This should be called election fraud.
So what can we do while we continue to sound
the alarm on this and demand that Dejoy be
trotted back to Congress to answer questions?
We have to just vote early, early, early,
or decide we feel safe enough to vote in person
depending on where you live.
You within just weeks will be able to make
a vote by mail.
If it gets delayed five days because of these
cuts, it'll still get there in plenty of time.
If you live in a state where you can believe
reasonably that you won't have to spend hours
in line with Marsalis people trying to vote,
maybe you decide, well, I'll vote in person
to ensure my vote is counted.
In some places you will be waiting in line
for hours with people without masks and maybe
you don't want to do that.
And it makes sense to just vote by mail as
early as you can.
All of these problems are by design.
We can't let them win at all, but we certainly
can't let them win like this.
Anyone who does not have a problem with this
is complicit in the eradication of democracy.
In this case, being done through the proxy
of the U.S. Postal Service, Trump is realizing
the race is too uncertain unless he rigs it.
As I said last week, Trump might be able to
win fair and square, although unlikely that
he would win the popular vote.
He might be able to win the Electoral College
fair and square, maybe, but it's too close.
It's too risky.
And so they're pulling out all the stops.
This is also, by the way, part of a bigger
Republican plan to get rid of government agencies
altogether, say that the United States Postal
Service is not up to the job.
Then you cut their funding to prevent them
from being up to the job.
Then you point to the problems you caused
to say, you know, we really should get rid
of that postal service.
They're not doing a good job.
Look at what they did during the 2020 election.
We have to be on red alert because that's
exactly what this is.
We'll have continued coverage of this on the
David Pakman show, Instagram at David Pakman
show.
We'll take a quick break and be right back
after this.